on Capitol Hill congressional Democrats
are urging President Trump to take
action on gun control at the same time
as they widen an impeachment
investigation Democratic leaders want
the president to get Senate Republicans
to vote on a house-passed bill to expand
background checks for gun purchases a
new poll shows 83% of Americans support
comprehensive background checks Nancy
Cordes is on Capitol Hill
Nancy any hope that there might be
movement on this well Democrats are
certainly making a full-court press
Anthony they're holding news conferences
and hearings and sending a letter to the
president urging him to put more
pressure on his own party but even the
president has backed off of his early
calls for much stronger background
checks to people in Washington can make
sure the background checks bill passes
Donald Trump and Mitch McConnell after a
series of deadly mass shootings
Democrats are calling for the
president's urgent personal intervention
to reduce gun violence what courage does
it take to support legislation that will
save lives they are pushing him and
Senate Republicans to back HR 8 the
house-passed bill that would close the
loophole that allows private gun sellers
and online sellers to evade existing
background check requirements the bill
might have prevented a suspect in Odessa
Texas from getting a gun that killed
seven people last month agency Amazon
macam paint trail eight of the top
Democratic presidential candidates
appeared in a video launched by former
Arizona Congresswoman Gabrielle Giffords
in a bold way save thousands of lives
this will be a moment of determination
but Republicans say they won't vote on
anything that doesn't have the
president's backing we have to protect
our Second Amendment very strongly and
we will always do that Democrats are
also ramping up their impeachment
inquiry the House Judiciary Committee
will vote Thursday to establish rules
for impeachment related hearings
Maryland Democrat Jamie Raskin says the
scope of the inquiry has widened to
include government spending at the
president's properties this president
has been collecting millions of dollars
in payments at the hotels the golf
courses the office tower and other
business ventures without even reporting
it to Congress so that's the Intolerable
to us Democrats are going to be looking
into the air force's use of an airport
near the president's Turnberry resort in
Scotland stops by Air Force planes at
nearby Prestwick Airport have increased
the Trump Organization and the airport
made a deal back in 2014 to send air
crews to the resort for a discounted
rate the president has denied knowing
about the stops and the air force now
says the visits were allowable but may
not have been advisable Tony all right
still a lot of questions Nancy for us
thank you very much